The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Now, this
is how we left on Tuesday.
We got to this point where we
had put a particle in a box.
We put a quantum mechanical
particle in a box.
And it was an
infinite square well.
And what's this called?
AUDIENCE: Energy levels.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Energy
levels, and what's
really weird about them?
AUDIENCE: They're discrete.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Yeah, meaning
if you have this one here
and then you have
another energy here,
can it have energy in between?
No.
Can that quantum
particle be in between?
No, in energy.
And so the question
was, can we connect that
to things like what we
see in the universe,
like the spectral lines?
So what I want to do--
there's a little
bit more we need
to do to do that connection.
And so I want to spend some time
today just going through that
and going to the hydrogen
atom, because this is not
the hydrogen atom.
It's not an infinite well.
And then from the
hydrogen atom, we'll
talk about how just
from that, just
by solving for
the hydrogen atom,
we literally have this
incredibly deep understanding
of the entire periodic
table and all of chemistry.
So it's a pretty
powerful thing to do.
So we're going to start
with a little bit of review,
and then this
real-world example.
And then I've got to tell
you a few things that
are really important, like you
have this thing called "spin."
So we'll talk about that.
We'll end with that, and talk
about how from this solution,
you get this--
pretty awesome, pretty amazing.
So some review-- so we went
through this on Tuesday.
So why did people even
need quantum mechanics?
Well, because things were
failing, and crumbling,
and catastrophing
all around them.
And so how long--
so classical atom, oh, no,
there's a classical atom.
Photoelectric effect
was one of them.
Who can explain
what happened here?
These are some of the
reasons why we needed
a new theory after 400 years.
What's going on with the
photoelectric effect?
Anyone remember?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: A description of the
phenomenon or why it happened?
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Yes.
AUDIENCE: OK, so basically,
you take some light.
You shine it at a metal, and
a bunch of electrons come off.
And if you increase the
intensity of the light,
the number of
electrons coming off
increases, but not
the energy, which
was sort of counterintuitive.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Why was
that counterintuitive?
AUDIENCE: Because if
light's not a particle,
it's just like a
wave, then you expect
if you're shooting more light
at it, that's more energy.
So if an electron gets
hit by a bunch of light,
you'd think it would
get a bunch of energy,
and you'd also get a higher
energy, but it doesn't.
And the solution
was that the photons
are produced by electrons
changing energy levels
or something like that.
And so they come in
discrete packets of energy.
And so when they
hit an electron,
they shoot it off at
some particular energy.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
And what's that?
AUDIENCE: It's
frequency dependent.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: It's just
dependent on the frequency,
exactly.
That's exactly right.
So does everybody see that?
So this was called the
"photoelectric effect."
And it was the reason Einstein
was given the Nobel Prize.
It's a very
important explanation
of this very confusing
effect, which
is that you increase
the intensity,
but the energy of
those electrons--
see what's happening?
You're shining light on a piece
of metal and electrons fly off.
And you can measure how much
energy those electrons have.
And you increase the
intensity of light,
and they don't have any more
energy, which was really
bizarre if light is a wave.
What Einstein said
is, no, actually, oh,
but it does depend on the
frequency of the light.
So that makes sense if
light can be considered
as particles of zero mass--
that's weird-- that have
an energy associated
with their frequency.
So that was really important.
The energy of
something you thought
was a wave, light,
actually can be considered
as a particle associated
with the frequency,
have the energy of a particle
associated with that frequency.
And then what was
the classical atom?
What's wrong with this one?
How long do we live
in a classical world?
What's the most we could
live in a classical world?
AUDIENCE: 10 to the
minus 12 seconds.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: 10 to the
minus 12 seconds, it's game
over.
Why?
What's happening?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Why?
What's happening?
So it's accelerating,
and we know
that an accelerating charge--
radiation, and it loses energy.
And if it loses energy,
it should just spiral in,
and that takes about 10
to the minus 12 seconds.
So we know that's
not true, either.
Actually, I wanted to
put this out there.
This is from Wikipedia, and it's
a sort of explanation of that.
And so if you want to
understand more and read more
about the classical
atom, get a book
on Lienard-Wiechert potentials.
I'm sure just the name
alone is inspiring you
guys to want to dig deep.
And those are the ones.
That's what you can do to
get the time-varying EM
field for a point charge
in arbitrary motion.
But look at that--
they're not corrected
for quantum mechanical effects.
So that's what was
such a problem.
This was right around 1900.
So they had it, but then they
tried to apply it to an atom,
and here's what happens.
It's accurate, but breaks
down at the quantum level.
Quantum mechanics sets
important constraints
on the ability of a particle
to emit radiation, i.e.,
it doesn't in an atom.
Sometimes, I think this is
kind of interesting to look at.
Basically, we have this
problem that an atom will
sort of self-destruct, and the
electrons just spiral down.
The solution really,
if you think about it,
is it doesn't do that anymore.
But now why?
Well, because of the fact that
particles are waves and waves
are particles.
And it comes from
the quantization.
So I want to make sure
that we're all on that page
by the end of today, that
we all kind of see that.
So that's the reason,
is because particles can
be both waves and particles.
Waves can be waves
and particles.
Everything is one happy family.
Can't we all just get along?
Here are some particles
going through slits.
Now what's happening here?
Actually, you can think
of this as a particle
or it kind of looks like
a water wave, doesn't it?
But see, that's the whole point.
That's what particles are.
So what's happening here?
Can somebody explain
why it's showing this?
What's going on?
We've got on the
left, how many slits?
AUDIENCE: One.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
And on the right?
AUDIENCE: Two.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
What's the difference?
AUDIENCE: Interference.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Yes.
What's interference?
AUDIENCE: Two different
waves, and you've
got peaks and troughs.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Yeah, so that
you get two waves coming out
of-- but look, the same particle
creates no interference here
because it just bubbles through.
But if you have two slits, it
can create two little waves.
And those interfere and
they cause complex behavior.
And that is what
blew people away.
And oh, by the way, you
can see that there's also
some really cool
interference going on
in the backscattering
from the edges,
because you get a
little scattering
off the edges on both cases.
But what we're looking at is
what's happening over here.
And so it's just really weird
that you could throw particles
through slits, and they
were like water waves,
not like particles.
That was another really
bizarre experiment.
And again, one of the big,
important stepping stones
was the fact that you
could describe the energy
of a particle by its frequency.
And then de Broglie came and
said, actually, not just light.
No, everything-- all matter--
can be considered as both
a particle and a wave.
This is stuff we
talked about Tuesday.
And so what that means is
that I have a wavelength.
What's my wavelength?
35, 10 to the minus 35.
But I'm OK with that.
I feel that quantum
is right here.
I feel it somewhere within.
But see, when things are really
small like an electron, which
is this part of the class--
we care about those electrons.
And I motivated that on Tuesday,
and we'll come back to that
as we go through examples.
So if I want to know
about an electron,
that's a really small thing.
And so its wavelength-- and
we talked about this Tuesday--
the wavelength associated
with the particle
is about the same
size as the distances
the particle sort of
goes out for a walk
on, on a daily basis, otherwise
known as its "chemical bond."
If you're an electron,
you kind of walk
along this chemical bond.
That's sort of what you do, if
you're in a bonding situation.
And that distance of that
walk is roughly the same
as your wavelength,
as your wave nature.
Your wave nature-ness
is important then.
And so because of that,
we can't describe it
without quantum mechanics.
You have to have a
way of describing it.
And it has to be something
that is based on a wave.
So that's the breakthrough.
And I'll go through
that again just quickly.
But what we came out with is the
fact that particles are waves.
So they have wave functions.
And this wave function is
what we'll be solving for.
This is what we want in
this part of the class.
We want that.
And so it'll have some form.
And we showed a few forms,
and I'll show you more today.
But we showed a few for
a particle in a box.
That had a cosine, and then
it had one node in the middle.
But what's amazing about this
is that this has no meaning
we know of.
We do not understand
what this means.
So you have this
intimate function
that describes the
particle, and we
don't know how to interpret it.
The big breakthrough came
in making the connection
that the square of that
function is meaningful.
But that's pretty cool.
So think about if
I had a position.
Wait, you had this--
you did classical
molecular dynamics,
so you have the position
of the particle.
That's a function of time.
Imagine saying that
that has no meaning,
or you don't know what it
means, only the square of it.
So something as
fundamental as the wave
itself that is the solution
to the equation to our f
equals ma, which is Schrodinger,
something as fundamental
as that, we don't
know what it means.
But we do know what
its square means.
And what does the square mean?
AUDIENCE: Probability.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Probability.
So tell me a little
more about that.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Yeah, so tell
me-- this is a particle right
here.
You're starting to
see it, I can tell.
I can see that you're
starting to see it.
I can feel the excitement
about this, too, in the room.
It's tangible.
This is a particle.
You see this now not as a
wave, not as a particle.
You see it as both.
Now, if this is a
particle and that's
why I'm going to show you a
little video on it in a second.
But if this is a
particle, where is it?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
by chance [INAUDIBLE]..
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: But
I mean, I know that it
can be a particle again.
We it can go back and forth.
That's what it did when you
sent it through the two slits--
it became wave, then
it became a particle.
So can I say that
it's spread out?
Is it spread out?
How do I interpret that?
AUDIENCE: The probability
of finding a particle is
2 to the negative 3.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Good.
That's sort of the way
that I like to look at it.
I mean, the particle is--
in a way, you can think
about it is spread out
until you measure it.
It's sort of everywhere in here,
because there's no here here.
There's only a certain amount
of chance to be here here.
So I have a kind of big chance,
if I measure where it is,
of finding it here.
And then I have no chance
And then it's sort of medium
chance here, and a big chance
there, if I measure it.
So that's really what
these functions mean.
And those functions
are the ones that we
solve for to find out
where electrons are.
And where those
electrons are is what
is absolutely critical to
doing a whole lot of material
science, as I
mentioned on Tuesday,
and as we'll talk about when
we apply this to problems.
And that's what you get.
You get bizarre distributions
of probabilities.
Here's an electron thrown
into a wall that is infinite,
and here is an electron thrown
into a wall that's finite.
So that's my quantum
mechanical ball.
Did I show this Tuesday?
I don't think I did.
So if it's thrown
into an infinite wall,
it actually can't go through.
The probability--
we worked this out.
If you have an infinite
boundary here--
we talked about that Tuesday--
you can't have any function.
The only solution is 0.
So it can't penetrate at all.
So it completely bounces
back, although look
at the weird things it
does when it bounces back.
That's the wave function of
a ball thrown into a wall,
or if you want, an electron
thrown into a material.
But over here, you
see it's not infinite,
and all kinds of
interesting things happen.
It does bounce back in a
similar way, but some of it
goes through.
What's that called?
AUDIENCE: Tunneling.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
Tunneling, right.
And you better
believe that this is
as effect we use in
technology all the time--
tunneling of charges,
very important.
If I take my macroscopic
ball and I throw it,
or if I just run myself with
a helmet on into the wall,
how much of me is
going to tunnel?
AUDIENCE: Not enough.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: What is
enough in that example?
So why aren't I tunneling
if I run into that wall?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: You're not
running fast enough.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
I'm not running--
so actually, that's true.
I'm pretty slow.
But the thing is that
there's another reason.
What is it about me that
is really different here?
AUDIENCE: You're big.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: I'm big,
and so what does that mean?
What's small?
AUDIENCE: Your wavelength.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
My wave function--
my wavelength, not
my wave function.
My wave function is everywhere,
but it just doesn't really
spread out that much.
Because the wavelength of
me is 10 to minus 35 meters,
and remember, when
quantum matters
is when your wavelength is sort
of on the same scale roughly
as the stuff you're
involved with.
And I'm involved with a thing
that's a meter over there.
So if I'm 35 orders of magnitude
smaller in my wavelength,
there's not going to
be any quantum effects.
You won't tunnel very often, not
enough to make it worth trying.
Now, here's the goofy
video, which is kind of fun.
So I'll just play it,
and then we'll move on.
[VIDEO PLAYING]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I love the music.
- A true giant of
quantum revolution
was Werner Heisenberg.
And from the vagueness of
positions of electrons and de
Beuys standing wave orbits,
he drew a tremendous insight,
which he stated like this--
"The more precisely the
position is determined,
the less precisely the momentum
is known, and vice versa."
And while it may seem like
a bunch of gobbledygook,
it was the insight necessary
to understand how an object can
be both a particle and a wave.
This single statement
led to the understanding
that subatomic particles
can disappear and reappear
in another place.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
That's really weird.
- And they can do
this without existing
in the intervening space.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
That's really weird.
- When an electron is
trapped inside an atom,
the places it can
disappear and reappear
include specific locations
around the nucleus.
And that makes it
look like a shell.
Basic particles can also be in
more than one place at a time,
if the time is brief enough.
An electron can travel
from here to there
along all possible
paths simultaneously.
And even more astounding,
these particles
can appear out of the
nothingness of space,
exist for an extremely brief
instant, and then disappear.
Scientists call them
"virtual particles."
They may be virtual, but they
can have very real effects.
All this jumping around
makes particle descriptions
so inexact.
But then existence itself is
inexact at these tiny scales.
The question is
often asked, what
is it that is wave
when a particle is
described as a wave?
And after a lot of
hem-hawing around the issue,
the right answer is,
existence is waving.
The particles are
jumping around,
coming into and
out of existence.
And those places where the
wave crests are maximum,
are the places where the
particle materializes
most of the time,
while the places where
the crests are minimum are the
places the particle avoids.
The wave is a map of the
particles' existence.
And as the wave changes, the
particle changes as well.
[END PLAYBACK]
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: There you go.
I love these kinds of
videos, and not just
for the soundtracks, because
those are pretty cool.
But I think that he
got a little bit ahead
of where I want to be, but does
everybody see that weirdness?
Is everybody getting
a feel for it?
OK, he said something
that's mind blowing.
What did he say that I
said was really deep.
Anybody remember?
AUDIENCE: Existence is waving.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Existence is--
well, yeah.
Oh, actually, there
were so many things.
You're going to have
to see this again.
And again, this is one of those
things-- you take this with Dr.
Quantum, was it Dr. Quantum?
You take this video
with you, too--
to the bars, to the dorms,
wherever you're going
to do your next social thing.
And you just see
what the response is.
You ask what their opinion
is, and it's a great way
to engage with people.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Does the wave
function exist all the time?
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Does the wave function
exist all the time, too?
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: That
is a good question.
And yes.
I mean, it's changing
all the time,
but it exists all the time.
Here's the thing,
though-- did anybody
catch the other thing
that's going on here?
I'm going to talk about
this at the end today.
But--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: OK, yeah,
I can't even go there,
that's so crazy.
What else?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Virtual particles.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Vertical
particles, vacuum fluctuations,
but we're not going
there either--
mind blowing.
I mean, in quantum mechanics,
stuff actually appears out
of nowhere.
Out of nothing
you get something,
and then it disappears.
Those are called
"vacuum fluctuations."
What else?
But it's all related to this.
Basically what he
said is that particles
can disappear and then
reappear somewhere else.
And actually, if you
take field theory,
which I really don't
recommend for most people--
I still remember my final
exam in field theory.
It was 90 pages long.
It was a 24-hour,
take-home exam.
Anyway, I still remember
asking my field theory teacher
in graduate school,
how can that be?
How can a particle disappear?
Because basically when
you get down to it,
that's pretty much
how things move
at the very smallest scales.
They disappear and
then they reappear.
That's what the math
tells us, at least.
How can that be?
I didn't get an answer.
This gets deep.
It's really cool and
really mind blowing.
And we just don't really know.
We don't connect it so much
anymore in the classrooms
to the mind-blowing
awesomeness of it all.
But I love it.
Now, I'll get to
that towards the end.
I'll come back to that.
Now, what we need-- so
we have these waves.
We know that particles are
waves and waves are particles.
And we know that
the particles we
care about in this
part of the class
are going to have to
be described by a wave.
How do we talk-- what's the
F equals ma of that wave?
It's dictated by-- it's
the Schrodinger equation.
That's it.
That's our f equals ma.
It's telling us how
this wave is going
to change in time and space.
And so we talked about that.
And we basically
just wrote this down
and said this is the equation.
We're not going to go into the
details of where it comes from,
but there's so many places where
you can read more about that.
But this is our
governing equation.
And basically, what
you have is a kind
of kinetic energy of the wave.
That's this del squared thing,
kinetic energy operator,
and a potential.
And that together, we call
h, we call the Hamiltonian.
That's got its own
special name because just
like T plus V in classical
physics is the energy,
we consider this thing, h
squared over 2m del squared
plus V to be the energy.
That's h.
But it has to act
on the wave function
in order to get that energy.
And that's basically what
the Schrodinger equation is.
Because we said,
we're going to say
that h doesn't depend
on time usually,
for the things we care about.
And if it doesn't
depend on time,
then we can get
rid of the t here,
and we could separate
the time dependence out,
which is what we do.
And we're left
with H psi equals E
psi, which is the
equation we need to solve.
And I'll come back
to it in a second.
Here's the bit on
Schrodinger I mentioned
that I think is amazing.
This is, again, from Wikipedia.
You see, he found
the standing waves.
See, there it is.
He found the standing waves
of this relativistic equation,
but the relativistic
corrections disagreed
with Sommerfeld's formula.
Discouraged, he put
away his calculations
and secluded himself
in an isolated mountain
cabin with a lover.
I find it amazing--
not that part, but I find it
amazing that seriously, he
had to be convinced.
See, he came back
from the cabin and he
decided that his earlier
calculations were novel enough
to publish.
It's a good thing,
because it's pretty much
one of the most important
equations of the last century.
And it's the equation
we will be solving.
That's why I think this
history is interesting.
OK, so there it is.
So we talked about how
you can take the f out,
because if H doesn't
depend on time, then
you can just set them
equal to a constant.
You can set each side
having its own function
dependent on its own variable,
r and t in this case,
and they equal a constant.
And then you get the Schrodinger
equation we care about,
which is the one we'll be
solving, which is H psi
equals E psi.
And then we did this,
and we said, well,
how do you solve it?
What if you have a very
simple particle in a box.
And the box's walls
go up to infinity.
Then you can solve it.
And it's because
you have basically
the particle is either
between 0 and L, in which case
here, then v is 0, and
so you get this equation,
or it's out here in this
region, in which case
V is infinity, which
means psi has to be 0.
That's the only solution.
And then this is the
interesting part.
And when you look at this, you
see that the general solution
is sines and cosines.
So we did that, but then there
was the very important thing
that happened.
What is it?
And you get a solution
for E. Once you
say the general solution,
you get a solution for E.
So this is just a
standing wave, and you
get a solution for E,
which depends on k squared.
But what's really
important that we did next?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
And that does--
yes, and what did that do?
AUDIENCE: It quantizes.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Quantizes.
Once you have the
boundary conditions,
it limits what this can be.
We didn't limit it until
we applied the boundary
conditions.
Then we applied the boundary
conditions and boom,
this thing is quantized,
and out from that
drops such a relief
for the world,
which can exist for more than
10 to the minus 12 seconds.
Because that quantization
is, in fact, the answer.
It's that those electrons can
only be at certain energies.
They cannot radiate energy
off of the atom and spiral
to the middle because they can't
be at another energy except
the one it's in, and
then the next one.
And it's real.
I think I may have
shown this on Tuesday--
that you can actually
visualize the spatial extent
of the orbitals.
And I put some more--
this is actually
cutting-edge research.
Visualizing the shape of
electrons is not easy,
but it can be done.
There's been some really
phenomenal breakthrough
experiments.
This was in Scientific
American a decade ago.
Now I want to move from
particle in a box to real stuff.
And the first real
stuff that's relevant
is hydrogen. And it's
only one element,
and I mentioned last time
that it's not necessarily
useful enough to do, say,
materials engineering.
And so you'd like to
have a little bit more
of the periodic table.
That's true, but you'll see
that with hydrogen alone,
we get our answers
to so many questions
about the whole periodic table.
And it is a real
useful material.
How much of the universe is made
of hydrogen, does anybody know?
AUDIENCE: 70?
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: That's
a really good guess.
It's about 75%.
That's a lot of hydrogen.
Now, how much of that
is in usable form on Earth
for the hydrogen economy?
How much hydrogen is usable
for hydrogen-powered cars
on this planet right now,
in an immediate form?
Zero.
That's part one of the
hydrogen economy problem.
You've got to make the hydrogen.
There isn't any more.
It's too light.
This planet's gravity
couldn't hold it.
So anything that was free, left
or bonded to something else.
You've got to make
the hydrogen. What's
part two of the hydrogen
economy problem?
Storing it.
So you've got two big problems
with the hydrogen economy.
I'm not saying it's
not worth looking at.
We will not be driving
around this way,
but I'll talk a little bit
more about hydrogen. I just
love motivating the topic
we're about to go into.
And since I want to talk
about the hydrogen atom,
I will talk a little more about
hydrogen storage materials.
And we will calculate
some properties of them
using quantum mechanics.
But I love this.
The history of hydrogen
is a very interesting one,
but I love going
back to Jules Verne.
In 1874, Jules Verne
said, "I believe
that one day hydrogen and
oxygen, which together
form water, will be
used either alone
or together as an inexhaustible
source of heat and light."
I love that.
Anyway, we're not
there, not even close.
I think a hydrogen
economy is a possibility.
And I think there's some
great research going on.
And it should stay as research
for at least another 30,
40 years.
I'll come back to--
it's going to need
about that much research
to really make an impact
in the energy scene.
I'll come back to that later.
So that's a little motivation
for hydrogen. Now here it is.
Hydrogen has a
proton, an electron,
and it's got some distance
that that electron sits away
from the proton.
What do I need to know?
Well, I need to
know the potential.
So what's the potential here
between these two charges?
One's negative, one's positive.
They feel an attraction.
How does it go with r?
Yeah.
It goes as 1 over r.
So now that-- I got my
V. It's the potential
that charges feel.
And that's got to go now into
the Schrodinger equation, which
I then need to solve.
And that'll tell me what the
possible wave functions are.
And so here's what
it looks like, see?
We had H psi equals E psi.
That's our master equation.
Then we said, that's the
kinetic plus potential.
And then we said, that's
the momentum term, remember,
we talked about Tuesday, which
is just a second derivative.
It's a second
partial derivative.
It's a del squared, and plus
this potential term, which
I now put in here explicitly
for the hydrogen atom, E
squared over 4 pi epsilon 0 r.
And that's the question
I need to solve.
And it turns out that you
can solve this exactly.
You can solve this
exactly, just like you
could the particle in the box
with the infinite boundaries.
And that's really cool.
So you've got an electron.
You've got one particle,
just one electron.
These are its
spatial coordinates.
And you can solve for
it in this potential,
in this 1 over r
potential exactly.
And the easy way to do that
is to switch it to spherical
coordinates.
So I won't go through
the math in detail.
There's literally like 100
sites and 50 Wolfram Alpha apps
you can look at that
go through this,
and really, really
wonderful material on this.
But basically, the key point
is that when you write it
in spherical coordinates,
you switch from XYZ Cartesian
to spherical coordinates, you
can actually separate this
into essentially three quantized
problems-- theta, r, and phi.
And so you can write psi
now as a function of the r
and a function of the theta
and a function of the phi.
And what ends up happening--
and then so you put that in.
And there's a
little bit of math.
It's actually not that much.
I'm not going to go through it.
But you put that
in, and basically,
just like that
particle in the box,
just like that, each one of
these variables gets quantized.
It gets its own
sort of E-type term,
and it gets a quantization.
So these are the
equations that it
leads to when you do the
separation of variables.
And I think I have-- yes,
and the quantization is--
I think maybe on the next page
I have the actual energies.
But the solution--
remember, just
like the quantization of a
particle in a box, the same
here.
It only can happen, you
can only have a solution,
if in this case,
we're going to have
a quantum number called n is 1,
2, 3, or something else going
up.
Or in this case, we'll have
a quantum number called l.
That's also, by the way,
the main quantum number,
the orbital quantum number, and
then we have this little m sub
l, which is the magnetic one.
How many of you
have not seen these?
So you've all seen these?
How many of you have seen this?
OK, so I'm glad to see
all the hands go up.
And so that's what you have.
And it's a very special case.
And how many of you remember
that s stands for "sharp?"
See, I forget that.
Seriously, did you all
remember this sharp principle
and diffuse?
And I love f, which
is "fundamental."
So I want to know what's not
fundamental about silicon,
which has no f electrons?
Anyway, I thought that
was an interesting label.
So this is how we designate,
from these quantum numbers,
which come from just solving
the Schrodinger equation for one
electron in a 1 over
r potential-- that's
how we get all of
these designations
that you're used to--
s orbitals, p orbitals.
And you see, you get
different wave functions.
You get these functions,
these same wiggly functions
that I've been showing you.
You get four different values
of these quantum numbers.
And those functions can
be plotted in space.
This is just given those
spherical coordinates
and the functions of
those, you can plot them.
And you see that they
make really funny shapes.
Why is this so important?
I said it on Tuesday.
Why is the funniness of
those shapes important?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Yeah,
because what am I looking at?
Actually, let's go
to the next one.
That's kind of fun.
What am I looking at here?
This is the 1s orbital of
hydrogen, 2s orbital, 3s, 4s.
Look at how they're all spheres.
They're all
spherically symmetric.
And then you go 2p
orbital and you see
that it has a different shape.
So its function, these
are wave functions.
Remember, the wave function
is-- what's the wave function?
Who knows?
Does any of you know?
If anybody has some ideas,
this is like an open problem,
an open discussion.
But what is interesting
about these?
So these are the wave functions.
From that, what can I get?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
Yeah, if I do what?
AUDIENCE: Square it.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Square it.
So these landscapes
squared tell me what?
Where the electron is.
And that is
incredibly important.
That's it-- where
is that electron?
Well, if you are fundamental
as opposed to diffuse,
you have some really bizarre
places you can be and not be.
You can't be anywhere
where this isn't.
That's the point.
It's a probability distribution.
It dictates-- basically, all
the behavior of materials
comes from these,
these distributions.
They dictate what
materials do and become.
Now in the hydrogen atom--
so what happens?
So you get these
shapes of the size,
and then you also get those E's.
And remember, we solved
for the E's and then
we put the boundary conditions
on, and then it was quantized.
And the quantization in hydrogen
can be calculated exactly.
So the quantization of the
energy levels in hydrogen
is exactly minus
13.6 over n squared,
where n is the principle
quantum number.
How many of you have seen this?
Sort of half.
So 13.6 eV over n squared
is the quantization.
That means the energy of an
electron in this first orbital,
that one up there, if I put
an electron in that orbital,
its energy is bound to
the atom by 13.6 eV.
So what does that mean?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: If you give it 13.6 eV
or greater, it'll become free.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Yeah.
That's the ionization
energy of that electron.
But hydrogen has all
of these other orbitals
accessible to it.
Maybe I could put an
electron up to another level,
like the 2s level.
And if I do that, it's
all the way up to 3.4.
So now it's only bound
by 3.4 eV in the atom.
And what does that make it?
Is it sort of less
stable, more stable?
AUDIENCE: Less stable.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Less stable.
So it'd be much more
easy to pull it off.
Now, do you think that that has
something to do with bonding?
You better believe it.
Where electrons sit in energy
relative to other electrons
in other atoms, or
in their own atom,
has everything to do with
how things bond together.
And that bonding is
the one that you've
been just fitting to like
a Lennard-Jones potential.
You've just been fitting it.
All that bonding is what you
just-- in classical physics,
in classical modeling, you have
to have some potential form.
And all of the
intricacies of the bonding
get swept up into that.
But you can see why
that's so much more
complicated than that,
just by looking at these.
OK, but now, that
series that we just
got from a simple particle
in 1 over r potential
explains all of these
levels that are observed.
So does everybody remember this?
And poor number six
who didn't get named?
What are these?
When you see these, what
does it make you think?
Spectral-- now explain what's
happening in the Lymann series.
What's happening?
AUDIENCE: You're moving from one
orbital down to the ground one
and it's emitting photons
at those wavelengths.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: And
why are they different?
Why do I have all these
different ones in one series?
AUDIENCE: The amount of energy
it gives off as it goes from n
equals 7 to n equals 1 is
different from n equals 2 to n
equals 1.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Yeah, exactly.
And if you go up to
2 and you stop at 2,
then you have other energies.
Because it all comes down to,
then, what the differences are.
To get an electron to
go from here to here,
you need the difference
in these energies.
And to go from here to here,
you need that difference.
No more and no less will do.
Now, when the electron comes
back down, what happens?
Anybody know what happens?
AUDIENCE: It emits light.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
It emits light.
It gives that energy
back out as light.
And that's what you
see when you look out
at these spectral lines.
So it emits light at
exactly this energy.
Can it emit light
at something else,
at a different amount of energy,
or a different frequency?
Because we know for
light, the energy
is equal to the frequency
times a constant.
Can it emit light
at this frequency,
something in between?
Why not?
AUDIENCE: Quantized.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
Yeah, it just can't
because it's a wave
problem that has
as its solution quantization.
And now, I come to the question
of, well then how does--
so that's what's happening.
That's the picture of these
electrons coming back down,
and emitting different
colors of light.
It explains what
people saw and couldn't
understand for so long.
This simple solution,
mathematical solution,
does it all.
It really crystallized
what was going on,
and it really confirmed
that this is the right way
to picture things--
the wave equation and
the Schrodinger equation.
Now, what's happening when
an electron goes from here
to here?
How does it do that?
It cannot go in between, but
we know it does do this all
the time.
We just look out in space and we
see it happening all the time,
but we can do it here.
We can build materials
that do this for a living.
Where are those electrons
going when they go from the 2p
to the 1s?
Where are they going?
Who can tell me?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: They're all sort of
described by a wave function,
right?
So it has some
non-zero probability
to be in one place and
a non-zero probability
to be in another place.
And if you hit it with
a photon or something,
or have some perturbation
to your hydrogen atom,
then it's going to have
a non-zero probability
to be in one electron
energy level than another.
And so it just sort of ends
up falling into one of them.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
That actually works.
That is a great interpretation
of what's happening.
And that actually works, and
it even works all the way down
to the nucleus.
By the way, decay to
the nucleus is possible
because those s orbitals--
I was just showing you a
slice of them, an isosurface.
But they have a non-zero
magnitude all the way down
to the nucleus.
It just won't happen very often,
because the probability is
so low that it's why
we have a universe.
If that overlap was more,
if the wave function
going into the middle--
if this is the nucleus
and this is the electron,
and the wave function of the
s orbital looks like this,
and it's almost 0, that's
why we are alive today.
But if this looks more like
this, no, we wouldn't make it.
There's just too much
probability for the electron
to decay into the nucleus, and
give off that amount of energy,
and the atom collapses.
So we should be very thankful
to quantum mechanics.
Now, there are
situations, though,
when you actually
have nodes in between.
And that's a tougher one.
The node means the wave
function goes exactly to 0.
Now what's happening?
And here, we go
back to this world
of particles, this field
theory world, basically, of how
particles move, by essentially
annihilating themselves
and reappearing.
That's how electrons
really move.
Now any questions
about any of that?
No questions at all?
OK, we're going to
start taking this
to the next level,
which is obviously going
to have to be more complexity.
There are some constants
that I'm just putting here.
I'm not going to
spend any time on it,
but these are the
constants you'll
be using in the quantum world.
We have an electron
volt. We have a Rydberg,
which is 13.6 electron volts.
And just to make it
interesting, there's
a Hartree, which
is a half of that.
And then the same with
angstroms and Bohr.
These are the kinds of unit--
do you say angstrom,
do you say Bohr--
to-may-to, to-mah-to--
you can choose, but just
keep track of it all.
Now, as we go to more complex--
so I've given you a
particle in a box,
and then I gave you a
particle, actually, on Tuesday,
in an oscillator.
And then I give you a
particle in 1 over r.
And that got us a long way.
We explained spectral lines.
We got hydrogen right.
But if I just add a little
bit more complexity,
you see things get really messy.
Now, this was a problem.
I wanted to show
how messy things get
with analytic solutions as a
kind of motivational exercise.
So I gave this on
a homework problem
in this class two years ago.
And I'll admit that
was probably a mistake.
I had a lot of people at
office hours, because you see,
this is the same thing.
I'm throwing my
quantum mechanical ball
into a wall that has
another wall behind it.
So can't you just set it up?
Well, sure, you can.
And this is what you get.
And you put that
into Mathematica,
which every single student
did, and it chokes--
can't do it.
Too many for Matlab.
I guess too many boundary
conditions, or too many
variables, or
something, but nobody
could get Mathematica
to do this without
some intelligent substitution
of variables first,
which was sort of the trick.
But my point in this was
not to make students suffer.
I don't like to do
that, but it was just
to convey how hard
this equation gets
to solve with just a little
bit more complexity than one
particle in a well or in 1
over r, or something like that.
It gets really hard, and
that's why we need computers.
And that's what computation
in the last 50 years has done.
It has made this, together
with some algorithms,
some simplifications
that you'll hear about--
it has made this
equation solvable
for much more complex systems.
So I can also say,
well, let's not
make the potential
more complicated.
Let's just add another electron.
So now, I'm still with
a 1 over r potential,
but I've got two of them.
So now, all of a sudden,
my potential term
is these electrons
interacting with the proton,
but also those electrons
interacting with each other.
That's r12, the distance
between the two electrons.
And boy, does that
make this equation
hard to solve analytically.
You cannot use
separation of variables.
So even just one more electron,
it's a deal breaker, basically.
And now you think we
want to do big molecules.
We want to do fullerenes.
We want to do silicon.
We want to do
thousands of electrons.
Analytic approaches won't work.
So what can you do?
Well, there are two
different ways to go.
You've got to do something.
You've got to make it easier,
because as you'll see,
an exact solution, even with
the most powerful computers
in the world times squared
are not going to do it.
You need to make approximations
to the actual equation.
And you'll hear about
those next week.
And one thing you can do is
you can use perturbation theory
to say that this Hamiltonian
is actually some simpler
Hamiltonian.
That Hamiltonian is
some simpler Hamiltonian
that you can solve easily
plus some perturbation to it.
We're not going
to really do that.
Has anybody used
perturbation theory?
So we're not going
to do it much but,
I'm just using it for reference.
And then, so you do
something for something.
Perturbation theory, what you do
is you say, well, that's hard,
so I'm not going to do that.
But this is actually kind
of related, and it's easy,
and I know how to do this.
So I'll do this and then
add something to it.
That's basically
perturbation theory.
But what we're
going to do is we're
going to try to solve it using
more of a matrix eigenvalue
approach.
And again, we are not going
to go deep into the math here.
And you will not be
tested on the math.
As I said, my goal here
is to have you guys
applying these equations
to real materials problems.
But I do think that it's useful
to know what's under the hood,
to know what equations
are being solved
when you press "Simulate."
So you'll hear more
about this, and how
you go about actually
making these approximations,
making the
approximations you need
to make in order to get
an eigenvalue problem that
can be solved on a computer.
There are a couple of
different ways to do that.
The way that we're going
to settle on in this class
is density functional theory.
So we'll talk a
little bit about that.
And again, the only Nobel
Prize in computation
was given for that, the
development of that theory.
Now, there's one more
thing I need to talk about
before I move to just
a couple of examples
online that I'd
like to show you.
And that is that there's
something still missing here.
So we've got-- let's
see, we've got this 1s.
So now we know where
these things come from.
We really know where they
come from, the solution
to the hydrogen atom--
2p, 3s, and so on.
And then hydrogen would be what?
How would I show hydrogen here?
Put an arrow there.
What would helium be?
One more.
OK, tell me carbon--
I like carbon.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
Carbon is right here.
It hits me in the
heart every time.
How many more?
AUDIENCE: Four.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: And then what?
AUDIENCE: Two up.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Two up--
oh, why not like this?
No?
It just feels wrong-- exclusion.
Now we're talking.
You guys already kind of
have a feeling for this.
But actually, you
can have materials
that violate someone's rule.
Anyone know what
that rule is called?
AUDIENCE: Pauli exclusions.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
Well, actually, this
doesn't violate
Pauli exclusions.
AUDIENCE: Hund's rule.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
Hund's rule-- very good,
whoever pulled that one out.
That was good.
But this is how
carbon usually looks.
Now, something that
we've done here
is we've already done what
I'm about to tell you, which
is we've put spin in there.
We've put those electrons
pointing up or down.
But we also have
those quantum numbers.
This is n.
N equals 1.
This is n equals 2, and this
is l equals 0, l equals 0.
And this is p.
So this is n equals
2, l equals 1.
And each one of these is an m.
m equals plus or minus 1 and 0.
So that's why I have three p's.
So those are those
quantum numbers
you get from quantizing the
solution to the Schrodinger
equation for an electron
in the 1 over r potential.
But there's this one more thing,
which was also very surprising
at the time, which
is that if you
put a particle, in
this case silver atoms,
if you think about electrons
as charges spinning,
you should have a reaction
to a magnetic field.
They should have
a magnetic moment.
But classically, you see, if
you have charged spinning,
you get a magnetic field.
Classically, if you shoot this
through a really large magnet,
you should just get a whole
range of lines of fields.
But just like the double slit,
it didn't turn out that way.
You got two dots
instead, only two dots.
And these are very famous.
These are the
Stern-Gerlach experiments,
which were done all
around the same time they
were figuring all this out.
And what it showed is that the
spin can only be up or down.
It can only be two things.
There's only two values for the
spin of an electron, the spin
being the thing that's
causing this thing
to have a magnetic moment
that's causing it to react
to the external magnetic field.
You should get a line.
You should get all this--
classically, electrons should
have any spin they want.
I don't know what that
was, but it should be
able to point in any direction.
But no, it can only point
this way or this way.
Now, is an electron
really spinning?
If a charge is spinning,
it has a magnetic moment,
but is an electron
really spinning?
How does it have
a magnetic moment?
Let's talk.
That's a really good
one, too, but it does.
And you think about
it as spinning
because that is our classical
Maxwell sort of ENN framework.
We think about charged spinning.
You've done it.
You make current go through
a wire, and you get a field.
And that's why we
use the word "spin."
It's sort of like "orbital."
Should we really be
using the word "orbital?"
Is this electron orbiting?
No.
And that's another
ice-breaking question.
You go to your friend,
and you just say,
do you think electrons
are really orbiting?
Just like that.
And see how many people say yes.
They kind of are
spinning in our minds.
But the spin is up or down
because of those experiments.
Now then, the sort
of end of the story--
so they have a magnetic moment,
and it gives them up and down.
And they can only
be up and down,
only up and down, two values.
And so what you have is sort
of a new quantum number.
You have spin, which is
equal to plus or minus 1.
That's that and that.
So now each of
these-- and that's
why with these collections
of quantum numbers,
you can get that many
electrons into those shells.
And I love this.
So somebody said
"Pauli exclusion."
Somebody tell me what the
Pauli exclusion principle is.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Two fermions
can't be in the same state.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: OK, so two
electrons, we'll just say,
which are fermions, cannot
be in the same state.
And what do you mean
by the "same state?"
AUDIENCE: That they can be in
sort of the same energy shell
with the same spin
at the same time.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: OK, very good.
Basically what it means is
they cannot have the exact same
quantum numbers.
Pauli exclusion says
you cannot do this.
Now, I mentioned you
can violate Hund's rule.
And you can violate
Hund's rule by having
degenerate orbitals
with the same energy,
and doing it there.
But usually, you don't.
Pauli exclusion is an
incredibly important aspect
of quantum mechanics.
It says that no two
electrons, fermions,
can occupy the same
set of quantum numbers
when you include spin.
That is what gives us literally
the periodic table and all
of chemistry when you add
that to quantum mechanics.
That is what gives us the rest,
that plus the hydrogen atom.
You don't need much
more, except you do.
But I love this letter from
Thomas to Goudsmit in 1926.
"I think you and
Uhlenbeck"-- because they're
the ones that discovered
this stuff in working out
the theory--
"have been very lucky to
get your spinning electron
published and talked about
before Pauli heard of it.
It appears that more
than a year ago, Kronig
believed in the
spinning electron
and worked out something.
The first person he
showed it to was Pauli.
Pauli ridiculed the
whole thing so much
that the first person became
also the last, and no one else
heard anything of
it, which all goes
to show that the
infallibility of the deity
does not extend to his
self-styled vicar on Earth."
So Pauli had an
interesting reputation.
But that is amazing to
me, because this is it.
This is one of the foundations
of the Pauli exclusion
principle, so Pauli built
his whole reputation
and really made an
important contribution
because of what apparently
he didn't really
believe in at first.
So it goes to show--
keep an open mind.
So that's what we just said,
can't have the same quantum
numbers.
Got to mix up the quantum
numbers, and that's it.
And that is it.
You see, because now, we had all
these levels from the hydrogen
atom solution--
an electron a one electron in
a simple 1 over r potential,
and we got all those levels.
And now all we need
to do is fill them up.
And with the Pauli exclusion
principle, we know the rules.
We know the rules.
We know we can only
put two electrons here.
put two electrons in s
and six electrons
in p, so eight here.
We know we can only put
two, six, and how many in d?
10, because n goes from
minus 2 to plus 2, so 5.
I mean, d has that.
So that's starting to sound
a whole lot like this.
That's it.
Essentially, with those
fundamental principles
that were worked out in
the '20s, and the solution
of the hydrogen atom,
you get essentially all
of the periodic table.
It's really powerful.
It's pretty darn cool.
And you can connect, as I said,
back to the spectral lines
and all of that.
Now, what I want to spend
the last couple of minutes on
is I wanted to show you-- has
anybody looked at the quantum
part?
You guys are still doing
homework from the last part,
right?
So on the NanoHUB, there is--
so you go to the
NanoHUB, and you go to--
sorry, I should check this out.
There I am.
That's amazing.
That's a picture from, like,
I won't say how long ago.
That's embarrassing.
So you go.
This is my personal thing.
But anyway, the tool
you want is this one,
and it has a little
star next to it.
That's so exciting.
It's called the "MIT Atomic
Scale Modeling Toolkit,"
formerly known as the Berkeley
Atomic Scale Modeling Toolkit,
because I developed
it at Berkeley.
So much for that,
but it's now at MIT.
And if you click that,
these are actually
tools I developed for a class I
made up when I was at Berkeley,
when I valued
sunshine over science.
It doesn't say that.
And you can launch it,
and you'll see that--
and you can rate it a 10.
Don't rate it anything else.
But please rate it,
or don't rate it.
Everybody is so star driven
these days, number of stars.
What was that?
There was an NPR piece
the other day about
how there's this whole business,
opportunity sprouting up,
of people who have
companies, where all they do
is they get your number of
stars for your products high.
So they have people
around the world,
because you've got to do
it from different places,
and you've got to write
fake reviews of products,
and have different fake
Google email addresses--
blowing me away, the
so-called internet.
Now, you look here, and you
see that actually in this MIT
Atomic Scale Modeling Toolkit,
there are many things.
There are many things.
We will be using
two tools from this,
and both are quantum
mechanical tools.
One is going to be GAMESS, which
is a quantum chemistry package.
It's free.
You can download it and run
it on your laptop, actually.
And it's for
molecules and atoms.
And another is going
to be called SIESTA.
So you play games,
you take a siesta.
And this one, we're going
to use when we do solids.
Both of them are going to
use an approximation called
"density functional theory"
to solve the Schrodinger
equation for real materials.
So let's just take, in the
last few minutes of class,
let's take a look at GAMESS.
And you can see--
why isn't it letting me-- it's
not letting me scroll down.
Seriously?
Oh, there's my scrollbar there.
OK, so the input is actually
pretty straightforward.
So you can calculate the
energy or you can optimize it.
The method is going to be DFT,
Density Functional Theory.
The basis set is something
you'll learn about on Tuesday,
what that is, but pick Medium.
And then I want to
not have a solvent,
but I want to plot
these orbitals.
And then, I think it
disappeared again.
Don't you guys love the NanoHUB?
It's so bug free.
And now it's not dragging.
It's great.
So what you can do
is you can do New,
and let's do the carbon
atom, my favorite one.
And I'm going to--
do you guys know
about XYZ coordinates?
So you put the number of
atoms in the top line.
You leave the next line blank
or you write whatever you want.
And, well, don't let me see some
of the things you might write.
I don't know.
And then you put the atoms
with their XYZ positions.
So carbon is going
to be at the origin,
and we click "Simulate."
And it's doing it.
That's it.
It just solved the Schrodinger
equation for carbon, something
you couldn't do for
a million years--
no, for 50 years--
analytically.
And it just did it.
And now it's still
executing a script,
which is very frustrating.
Is it this slow for you guys?
This is one atom.
Man.
Well, so we go back to here.
One thing you got
right there is you
got those energy levels, which
I can't scroll down to look at.
This is so amazingly
frustrating.
So now, what I'm going to
do, since it's not working,
is I'm going to try it again.
And I'll pick a
different basis, low.
See if that works.
And I just did the Schrodinger
equation for carbon.
You've got to be kidding me.
Really?
Seriously?
Let's try a different atom.
Let's try-- somebody
give me an atom.
AUDIENCE: Boron.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: All right,
this is going to be lucky.
This is going to do it.
Oh, yeah, It's not
able to do it--
unbelievable.
Let me just try one more thing.
I'm going to try
putting two atoms in.
Let's see if that helps.
And we'll optimize it.
Yeah, now it is a party.
Oh, OK, but did it
give me the orbitals?
No.
Hang on.
Sorry, guys.
Oh, it's still here.
Let's just see if it
gave me the orbitals.
OK, there they are.
OK, this is it.
It was Firefox, which I never
use, but it came to the rescue
for this one.
So look at this,
just really quickly,
because if you want
to play with this,
this will just take
one minute to show.
OK, there, I did
the carbon dimer.
That's a lot of electrons,
and it just solved it.
Because of what you're
going to learn on Tuesday,
the approximations,
it just solved it.
And look-- if you right
click on top of the image,
you get surfaces, and
then you get orbitals.
And look at that--
that is actually-- what do
you think those two are?
There are two
carbon atoms here--
the s's.
Those are those 1s's
together in the dimer.
And these are now the 2s and
p's, all bonding together.
And you want to
know how they look?
Well, here's one of those s's.
There it is.
It's an S orbital in
the dimer, though.
And it looks very much
like the atomic s orbital,
which it should.
Why?
Remember, those are the
ones we don't care about.
They don't really do
anything when you bond.
It's all about the other
ones, like for example,
one of these p's.
That's it.
That's the solution
to the Schrodinger
equation for the carbon dimer.
And that's where
that p-type orbital--
that's where the electron
in that level sits.
And this is no longer an atom.
You can do it for
the carbon atom,
and see the p orbitals
and the s orbitals,
but now when you
make a molecule,
things get more complicated,
and more and more complicated.
So that'll be the tool we
use for our molecule things,
assuming it actually works.
And if anyone has any
questions, email me.
And remember, class next
Tuesday, but not next Thursday.